here with the hey that isn't my birthday
hi I'm Greg this is Amy our bird hi guys
if you guys haven't met Amy or seen her
before she's made a lot of appearances
on my brother's channel Jabbok away and
I said get over here and now she's here
making an appearance she has her own
YouTube channel little by little she
will dominate the youtube sphere go
check out her YouTube channel today Amy
and I actually met at a screening for
spider-man far from home we did we're
gonna watch a video from new rock stars
called spider-man far from home
mysterious sightings revealed I mean
Neil not sure exactly what this is
referring to new rock stars is one of my
favorite YouTube channels have you seen
the arak stars before but I'm getting an
education here they miss you
incredible breakdowns did he get the
best Easter Egg is the best theories I
love love these guys so they'll go
frame-by-frame and so I guess from the
title that means there's more moments
and spider-man far from home where
Mysterio was there than we realized
okay so I guess it's always gonna break
it is quite mysterious yes yes yes a I
don't know how to yes and that other
than yes and rock stars I'm Erik Bosse
in spider-man far from home it's now
available in digital HD like me a chance
to truly go frame-by-frame through this
film and for gay to savor every precious
second of Tom Holland Peter Parker's
final hours in the Marvel Cinematic you
what are the Queen's Easter eggs I've
been catching two miry watches you
realize I'm wearing a wonder we'll make
sure that I'm sorry Stark Industries
still works William get Arriba dude
ermine Janice Victoria all these folks
there dude an impressive ability of
blending in and hiding in plain sight
like these villains wear under Peter
Parker's nose the whole time
infiltrating this
striking distance of ruining his life
hell you could even say that by the
post-credits scene t Mysterio truly did
win in that regard along with the video
war bar ferme home is the only MCU film
to end in utter catastrophe for the hero
I mean shirt Ragnarok ended with an
entire home planet game destroyed
[Laughter]
Mysterio in their London disguises as
Beck made a pony bone called Nick Fury
from their bunker whose larious each
team members wearing goofy costumes
crisps bicyclists and like the costumes
they wore in that progbar it reminds us
that these conspirators are freaking
master of disguises yeah okay carefully
they're hiding all over this movie so in
this episode I'm gonna break down every
team Mysterio sighting that we
overlooked the first time we watched far
from home okay the first hidden shining
Sun again Dennis long before Peter
shakes hands of Quentin Beck even before
Peter fights what he thinks the Marilia
elementals alongside what he thinks is
Mysterio in the background on the left
there is a tourist wearing a hat and
Hawaiian shirt around there's a beard
all that is cool for them before - all
right these brands ever come back to
have a Ben Sarah watch that eyewear and
keyboard was like
Christel scratch-resistant good look and
feel of luxury watches ten times the
price of their yeah yeah world why do
you feel better looking
okay back to t Mysterio creeping around
there are even more sightings and
possible sightings throughout the
streets and canals of Venice
after Peter buys really yeah MJ stroll
along the canal and briefly passing them
giving them a look Oh guys storyteller
MT Mysterio he crafted all the
narratives of the background there might
be some sightings or the rest of the
team like it's Peter leaves a shock
there's a blonde woman at a fish counter
on the left side of frame looks a bit
like the blonde in t Mysterio has the
same stress and right before cute shows
up and steps in the distant background
there's a bold man who might be willing
get your Eva though I guess stretching
and shortly after that there's a woman
with dark hair passing behind Peter
mange looks a bit like Janice the team
member who notified the others that Tony
start playing to be queasy and some of
the others were stalking Peter before
the purchase but it wasn't Peters
interference that put him on a collision
course of T Mysterio this wasn't an
accident at all this team pre-selected
Venice as an attack location because
they knew that Peter Parker would be
there and would receive Tony serve any
classes which of course is a real thing
if they were after in fact it's possible
that T Mysterio was even more involved
in Peters wholesome her plans
think about it we never quite know why
Peter and his friends are going on this
euro trip and later on the Shepherds
joke that it's supposed to be a science
trip but at no point do any of them do
anything fancy they're seeing the sights
with museums festivals
suddenly changed with really ways to
redirect beer to bring him closer to the
action
Peter Annette thought it was Nick Fury
hijacking their summer vacation but
really this whole operation was
orchestrated by Mysterio so what if the
whole trip from the beginning was an
offer by this team designed to extract
Peter out of his seat to make it more
vulnerable to classes if these folks can
trick millions of people with holo
projected monsters attacking major world
cities they can definitely bring up a
dozen international flights and
itineraries the team just so
effortlessly slips in and out of these
travel happier crazy comes the group's
tour bus driver in London and later he
abandons them on a Tower Bridge and if
you look closely can be seen leaning
against an archway near the Tower of
London and the kids run past him with
this level of control it is amazing that
any of the kids are Midtown high made it
out of this alive and there's one final
new detail I spot in the rewatch that
tells us just how close T Mysterio got
to completely awesome Peter burger the
moment Quentin Beck appears to be dying
and he appears to hand back the eated
glasses of course this is just a
projection the way he's holding those
glasses matches the way that the real
Mysterio in beside Peter is aiming a gun
at his head Peter catches him deflects
the shot at the last second we were
gonna have time to breathe a sigh of
relief it happened so fast but this is
one of the many moments we nearly saw
Peter Parker material not just splinter
back but the whole team is the most
affected ensue villain besides Thanos
really no one else so devastatingly just
seems the hero
indices several others including Nick
Fury and Maria Hill not just a scroll
versions of these characters but
presumably the real Nick Fury because
that Nick Fury thought it would be safe
to leave Peter and Talos with Quentin
back in post credit scene Matthias
reported to Nick Fury that everything
was okay presumably fury must've thought
everything would have been okay - so
Mysterio infiltrated everyone's defences
they messed him up real bad and they
ruined Peter Parker's life and still
there's also enough evidence to suggest
that Clinton Beck might not even be dead
go check out that
how do you think comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and a boss and subscribe to do
rock stars or the breakdowns of theories
or in everything marble thank you for
joining me and just say no Philip and I
are also similarly locked in a battle of
controlling a rock star Wow so right
aren't they yep you got it oh no
now you're comfortable so great at this
they're great at the breakdown right ah
that blows my mind that just made me
appreciate the movie so much more I was
sincerely shocked I was like what
welcome I thought I was like as soon as
he said team Mysterio's like okay that
makes sense cuz there's no way Jake
Gyllenhaal has shown up on screen and
we're not noticing yeah
Jake Gyllenhaal and Mary was in the
Hawaiian shirt it's like the there's
some of those we were like I don't know
about that
yeah when you do breakdowns and theories
you're usually kind of stretching on
some points that you a bit maybe but no
that moment with Mysterio in the
background it does kind of change the
what he was talking about does kind of
change the perspective of the whole
movie yeah because it did seem a little
bit by happenstance and some of these
scenarios it starts off with Mysterio
meeting Nick Fury and Maria hill and
then spider-man just happens to show up
it seems like Mysterio's team did
manipulate this from the very very
beginning of it all in order to try to
get spider-man to come out there that is
so crazy
the whole thing with Mysterio I've
always loved him as the I thought Jake
Gyllenhaal was great I didn't put his
villain up there is one of my favorites
but somehow some reason after watching
this video he's now quickly become one
of my favorite villains just for how
brilliant and evil he is I liked him
because he made you laugh and I loved a
villain that can make you have to like
he's sort of love/hate them you know
he's the bad guy but that whole like
director thing like no no right like I
just could not get enough of that so I
really liked him like like the Hitler in
movies is really funny yeah cuz he's
ordering people around yeah yeah I am
yeah see so it's okay to
for me a non-jew to make this Hitler
maybe in different categories we'll see
is he an anti-semite I don't know no he
there's one thing with Syria was he was
well I would hope there's one thing you
really cared about he was a progressive
that was mysterion equal right there's
your next spider-man movie right there
Sony in case you're looking for one a me
you right - right yeah I do well on
occasion if Sony's watching me they'll
ask you for a favor hire me think
especially if you want to remain
progressives Oney yeah what he said
every time you hire a man it's one step
down the ladders shall we say there's a
ceiling joke there yes I can't think of
conversations go through to answer the
question of how I think he compares to
other villains I think he's a perfect
one for spider-man because we got kill
monger and dannis were my two favorite
villains out of the MCU but what I loved
so much about what Mysterio did was he
really pushed spider-man to the breaking
point he pushed him to the edge like one
of my favorite kinds of protagonists and
I think DiCaprio does a great job in a
lot of his films when he's getting to
like the boiling point of losing it yes
Tom Holland in like the last thirty
minutes of this movie like when he goes
to see happy happy shows of a plane he's
like oh really
eyes are red he's freaking out he's
injured even in that moment witness
serial when he catches the gun you could
just see the spider-man himself has been
pushed to the edge so maybe their
relationship with each other isn't
personal but their interaction becomes
the most personal in terms of villain
vs. hero die no matter how far he was
able to make spider-man succumb to his
villainy plans and so to me that makes
him one of the top villains because of
how personal it became over time oh yeah
yeah it's a villain unless of us sort of
like punch you in the face way and more
a very calculated
fill in and I think that's cool oh yeah
did he say Mysterio was the best next to
Thanos was that what he was saying well
I'm not sure I mean send all this
objective but if you're like I think
they're totally like you can't
necessarily compare them because Thanos
to me is this like alien ass no to me he
was just a very like comic book universe
villain which is awesome it's super fun
but Mysterio Mysterio pretended to be
spider-man's friend yeah and then he
betrayed him and there's a whole other
level of evil there right their nose is
never like yeah I mean the one thing
Fanus is a friend he was always honest
then Venice was always very had his
weird integrity of being peccable with
his word his intentions really were to
eliminate half the human population
spoilers I think what he was talking
about in the video was how infinity war
in far from her own the only movies that
really end with the heroes that's what
he pretty much losing to villains
yeah and that is a good point see far
from home the one time yeah me too and I
think this video has really elevated my
appreciation a lot for far from home and
I mean that's the most you can really
assess it deserves a second watch the
yes Ann's are a little bit rough around
the edges today alright guys well thank
you so much for being here if you guys
haven't done so yet make sure to
subscribe to new rock stars you can
subscribe for the real rejects Amy's
channel go check it out as soon as you
can subscribe follow her on Instagram go
to her tumblr find her gmail account
there's a way where through the process
of the dark web you can find her phone
number
there's many ways to get in contact with
Amy and she welcomes all avenues so do
that today
I would like to give a patron of the day
I do that all the time I like to give a
patient the day shout-out to a man named
Taylor Bentley Taylor and I we've been
talking a lot recently and he's gone
through some pretty significant ups and
downs but Taylor I want you to know but
that last shout out was very sarcastic
wasn't aware of some things you read
over there at the time so I'm gonna take
this time to be really sincere I want
you to know that I really appreciate the
hell out of you dude you've been
incredibly supportive to us and you
really don't ask for like anything from
us literally the definition of ultimate
support and I want you to know that no
matter what you're going through that
even though we haven't met in person yet
you have my love and Amy's only just
heard of you but now she loves you we
all go through tough times and I'm sorry
and it will get better I promise
time heals all and also pounds of
cocaine that can be helpful at times
most times in between come during
commercial breaks yes so in moderation
everything in moderation twice a day not
in the presence of others don't do coke
jam Taylor dude why'd you bring that up
no I don't think so we're cutting